I gave you 10 years to live your life now
you see me rise and where did that get you
you walked in my shadow
i trained you
so the most dangerous people
in the world couldn't kill you
son it's time for you to
take your place by my side
you can't out run
who are you
oh god hold on everybody
we make a good team
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
marvel shang chi trailer video they finally
release footage for the movie it's coming out
this september there's a whole bunch of easter
eggs here obviously this is the real mandarin of
the mcu so we'll break everything down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos obviously there's a whole bunch
of new mythology that marvel is working into the
mcu with this movie these characters or at least
some of them like the mandarin have supposedly
been around for the entire existence of the mcu
events i'll explain what they're saying about the
mandarin's backstory they're combining a couple
different characters for some of what's happening
during the movie as you could probably tell
within the mcu the mandarin will be shang chi's
real father which is a little bit different from
his comic book backstory going the star wars
route only imagine your father was the emperor
most of you probably know simu liu from kim's
convenience on netflix but he's done a bunch of
other stuff as well so you probably recognize him
from at least somewhere aquafina obviously playing
his best friend that he meets when he goes out
into the world sort of leaves his father but as
you can see the whole idea here is that his father
the mandarin whose real name is wen wu during the
events of the film like he actually does have a
real name a real identity aside from the mandarin
wenwu the mandarin is basically training his son
to be his chief lieutenant now the really badass
looking ninja in the mask that you see in the
flashbacks when he's a little kid training and
in present day is death dealer sort of like his
chief lieutenant most of these are all characters
from the comics if you're not familiar but some of
them come from the master of kung fu comics some
of them come from the straight up shang chi comic
book title which didn't really happen until after
the 70s after marvel was introducing their own
version of a bruce lee type character and that's
basically who he's built to be inside the mcu
here marvel's version of bruce lee so this is
sort of like marvel's version of enter the dragon
so to speak only there are real dragons as you see
flying around in this giant battle scene in what
looks like a really big flashback to ancient china
but obviously the other big thing that they show
you here is the actual 10 rings like the 10 rings
of power inside the mcu so obviously we have
the real ten rings organization which we saw
in the first time during the iron man movies like
the first iron man movie the second iron man movie
later you even see that members of the 10 ring
have infiltrated hydra as well like you see the
tattoo of the 10 rings inside the first ant-man
movie so it's sort of their way of weaving them
into the backstory the tapestry of the mcu history
like they've been here this whole time we just
haven't really known what's really going on but
they do actually have the 10 rings of power like
you see in the iron man comics it's just the way
they're explaining them is a little bit different
so as you can see on the mandarin's arm here this
is who this is meant to be even though they don't
show his face in this giant battle the giant rings
look more like bands that he wears around his arms
obviously you can't see all 10 of them but that's
basically what these are meant to be and in
present day you see him attack that parlor there
he smashes his fist down you see that blue energy
rise up like here you can see shang chi in his
full-blown comic book costume fighting his father
in his comic book costume wearing the ten rings
all lit up in what looks like present day with a
lot of these other same monks or whatever's going
on in the background of the fight of this temple
like one of these fights at this temple seems
like it's happening in ancient times and one of
it seems like it's happening in present day and i
know a lot of you are asking is iron fist going to
show up during the shang chi movies maybe during
the sequels there is something of an easter egg
here on the car like you see fist written on the
side so you could think of that as a reference to
iron fist just a subtle wink they haven't fully
explained his comic book costume if there are any
special abilities that it has or fishes to costume
itself and all the power flows from him but the
whole idea is he's trained is this really badass
fighter and i think the idea is that eventually
he might wind up wielding the power of the ten
rings if he winds up defeating his father during
the film but most of this is all meant to be brand
new mythology for the most part obviously there's
going to be a bunch of mcu easter eggs and iron
man easter eggs because the mandarin is a huge
iron man character but the only familiar thing
you might recognize here is the streets of san
francisco because that's where they're crashing
this bus through as you see aquafina trying to
stop the bus is razer fist and his men who is a
comic book character is trying to fight shang chi
while they're in the process of crashing the bus
but basically you have the mandarin trying to
compel him to come back and take his place at his
side shang chi basically doing the luke skywalker
thing saying i don't want to do that so like i
said very star wars-y come to the dark side of
the marvel force if you're not a big comic book
reader though the change that they made to his
backstory is that in the comics his father is
this evil sorcerer called foo manchu so they're
kind of combining the fu manchu character with
the mandarin of the mcu i know we're all hoping
to see trevor show up somewhere during the movie
just some references to the iron man one shot all
hail the king when the real mandarin supposedly
had his man break into the prison to capture him
to make him a tone for using his name in public
how dare you besmirch my name by using and calling
yourself the mandarin the whole reason that kevin
feige made that marvel one shot was to tell people
no no no there is an actual real mandarin in the
mcu and he's super pissed off but that was years
ago when they released that and i know a lot of
you are now asking because of this ancient battle
here it looks like some of them are wielding qi
like what is this energy that's radiating from all
these sticks they're fighting with that probably
has something to do with the history of the 10
rings inside the mcu that could be their chi that
they're wielding it could be some sort of other
alien energy the whole idea with the 10 rings of
power at least in the comics is they actually are
made by this alien race of dragons who then crash
land on earth the mandarin a long time ago in
history finds their crashed spaceship and takes
the rings for himself becoming the modern day
mandarin but in the comics he's also extremely
long-lived like the rings themselves give him
almost eternal life the way some of this trailer
footage looks it also seems like he is extremely
long-lived like some of these fight scenes seem
like they go back hundreds and hundreds of years
just based on the way people address but it's kind
of hard to tell because the footage doesn't look
any different than the modern day footage but for
the most part shang chi's backstory in the comics
is that he is trained by this great villain phu
manchu who wants him to join him in his criminal
organization but shang chi decides that he wants
to be good and eventually winds up fighting
on the side of the avengers the other good marvel
characters he also eventually leads his own team
called agents of atlas but he does cross over with
the avengers characters obviously the whole idea
with Shang Chi's character in the mcu is that he
will eventually show up in avengers 5 and be on
one of the next avengers teams he's sort of like a
black panther style character who is very powerful
in his own right and obviously has this birthright
obviously a little bit different than black
panther's birthright but whereas the black panther
movie introduced this whole african mythology to
the mcu shanxi is doing the same thing with all
this brand new eastern asian mythology introducing
that to the mcu like a really cool easter egg here
that you probably spotted during this big fight
scene you see the fu dogs that you normally find
as statues at chinese temples you actually see
are real and running around like giant food dogs
running around fighting in this battle but also
all these tiny little dragons the race of dragons
is called the maculans i don't know if they're
actually going to explain that these tiny dragons
that are flying around in this big fight scene are
the maculans themselves or they're going to be a
little bit different there were some funko toys
of the actual dragon they just called the great
protector so i don't know if that's going to be
their version of fing fang fume inside the mc and
that's going to be the way they explain that or
if we'll see an actual fing fang fume easter egg
but there is supposed to be an actual big dragon
during the film and i believe that's supposed to
be the quote-unquote great protector like when the
mandarin captures shang chin brings him home so
to speak back to wherever he comes from with his
friend katie here aquafina's character you see
him standing in front of this mural you see a
giant chinese dragon in front of him then all the
water sort of comes out and stops mid-air and he's
staring at it that dragon seems like a depiction
of the great dragons that you see flying around in
this battle in the background but a couple of
the easter eggs for other characters that you
see running around in the background here that
they don't completely explain so in this fight
scene here you see the person in white that's the
mandarin like he's walking around in the white
costume in present day when they come back to this
10 rings home base you see him in the white suit
fighting this person in the green uniform with the
hat on that's supposed to be jiang lee's character
i'm not totally familiar with who she's supposed
to be but michelle yeoh is also in the movie she
might wind up playing his mother or another
character the person that you see him fighting
here in this mma style looking ring is actually
his sister xialing so they haven't seen each
other for a while when the events of this pick
up obviously she's meant to be a badass as well
it's not really clear what their relationship is
here or what her storyline is going to be during
the film but it does sound like she was also
raised and trained by their father the mandarin
to take her place fighting at his side i think the
whole idea though is that the mandarin wants shang
chi to be his successor eventually even though
it does seem kind of like he has eternal life
from the power of the ten rings the ten rings of
power and the comics are sentient kind of like the
infinity stones are sentient but their different
names are the remaker the influencer spin spectral
nightbringer demonic incandescence lightning zero
in the liar and they all serve different functions
they have different powers so people can use one
ring at a time or they can use multiple rings at a
time the mandarin obviously using 10 rings all at
the same time to make himself almost all powerful
within the mcu but they're not meant to be as
strong as the actual infinity stones it's not like
the 10 rings are replacing the infinity stones but
they are sort of like a macguffin during the movie
i'm assuming marvel's going to change at least
a couple things about their backstory just to
explain because you have this giant fight here
and it seems like their energy flows from the
same source as this energy the other people that
are fighting them at the temple not really clear
what they're fighting over in this giant ancient
war here at the chinese temple but this does look
like they're going to tell you the origin story
of the mandarin himself like before he became
the mandarin who was he and one of the other
interesting things about the trailer footage
you'll notice is that it doesn't really give you
any dates or hard dates for when it actually takes
place in the timeline so i'm assuming that a lot
of this will be taking place after the events of
avengers end game but they're obviously probably
flashbacks to before the snap before avengers
infinity war avengers end game like i think
the whole idea is that in present day after
the events of avengers end game shang chi is a mid
20-something relatively young guy so he'll still
be in his 20s when we get to avengers 5 and he
winds up joining the next squad still pretty young
person but older than spider-man say like peter
parker and the mcu a while ago there was a rumor
that they were going to do a very enter the dragon
style tournament setting for the movie in present
day at least i don't know if that's going to be
the same thing during this because you obviously
see him fighting his sister in the ring here
zealing but i think that comparison was only meant
to be loose like they're not literally doing the
plot of enter the dragon it's just doing a very
bruce lee style film within the mcu but because
they say that the mandarin has been around for
the entirety of the events of the mcu like he was
here during the events of iron man 1 like with the
exception of the eternals who go back thousands
of years in the mcu i'll talk about them in a
second too because obviously we haven't gotten
an eternals trailer yet mostly though you think
of the mcu you think of the first captain america
movie as the beginning of the events of the mcu
in the 1940s so when they say the mandarin has
been around for this entire time for the events of
all these things i'm assuming they'll explain how
he's lived so long and that'll probably be tied to
the explainer behind the mcu version of the 10
rings so even though you don't see a lot of it
in this trailer here during the movie there'll
probably be easter eggs and references to other
major mcu events in history like obviously they'll
probably reference the snap in the blip and even
though the mandarin is this huge iron man villain
in the comics i'm not expecting to see robert
downey jr cameo during the film in any flashbacks
potentially obviously he's dead in present day so
i don't think they're gonna bring iron man back
in present day but there are a lot of ways they
can weave in iron man easter eggs because you
have all that ten ring stuff happening in the
first couple of iron man movies you also have the
other characters like randall park and the ant-man
characters who live around the san francisco
area so we might see jimmy wu show up during
the film at some point too because i know after
Wandavision everyone's hoping for him to be the
close-up magic version of colson now in the modern
day mcu just popping up in everybody else's films
i do expect jimmy woo to come back for ant-man
3 but i don't know when that movie is supposed
to take place relative to the events of the
shang chi movie i'm assuming that shang chi
in present day takes place before the events
of ant-man 3. but in marvel's release schedule
for movies this year black widow is coming this
summer right before shanxi in september so i'm
assuming we'll get another shang chi trailer or
like a full shanxi story trailer which will tell
you more about what's actually happening during
the movie sometime this july but if you spotted
any big easter eggs or other references to marvel
movies or avengers end game avengers infinity war
or anything else the iron man movies just write
them below in the comments and obviously we're
gonna slowly learn more about these characters
marvel release more details in the next couple
of months so of course i'll do new videos for the
movie where you wait for everything everyone click
here for my new falcon and winter soldier episode
6 finale trailer video and click here for that
iron man one shot all hail the king with that big
mandarin scene of them revealing the real mandarin
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!